now here's a hot take Rolling Stone
magazine featuring a writer who argues
that cancel culture is actually good for
a democracy and will liberate us all he
goes on to say this leveled the playing
field for those who can't always rely on
the government to protect them and is
the poison to those in power that have
benefited from unchecked free speech and
here's someone hoping not to get
canceled Don Lemon returning to CNN
after making sexist comments about Nikki
Haley being past her prime he apologized
on Twitter but not on air after
undergoing formal training that seemed
to be making light of the situation
physical health up there you go and
mental health up here that was awesome
to jump there you go
are you getting too old for that yes
we're all young enough at heart so I
wouldn't worry too much all right that
was a good little quit by her
um Piers I gotta go to you what happened
to Rolling Stone magazine look I don't
believe in Castle Godzilla at all but
I'm prepared to make an exception for
Rolling Stone magazine what a load of
absolute gov and let me give them a
simple example of where canceled culture
actually was potentially horrendous for
democracy because this is still the
thing that alarmed me most in probably
the last few years about cancer culture
the New York Post for whom I write
columns
had a brilliant story it was a
completely true story it involved a
laptop belonging to Joe Biden's son
Hunter and they splashed it all over the
front page and the woke ravaged
management at Twitter
canceled the story they literally
canceled it they deleted the story and
they deleted the new post Twitter
account until they removed their
entirely true story that was just a few
weeks before the election
a lot of polling synths has shown that
if the voters had known that story
properly if it had been properly
followed up by the mainstream media most
of whom took the line it was Russian
disinformation which was a lie had they
done that it could have swung it could
have swung the election to Donald
Trump's way
and if that isn't a perfect example of
cancel culture working in many invidious
ways but in that case specifically to
thwart democracy and perhaps to change
the results of a U.S election I don't
know what is so yeah you can talk about
all the individuals people like JK
Rowling who get canceled because they
think a woman is an adult female you can
talk about all those people and some
survive and some don't but this goes on
right at the top and has incredibly
serious consequences so Rolling Stone
have got it completely wrong it's the
opposite Council culture is terrible for
democracy well and also judge we do know
a lot of the celebrities and their
stories but there are a lot of people
who are not celebrities who have ended
up on The Cutting Room floor and their
lives have never been the same yeah the
truth is that you know that when you're
canceled it's like a Scarlet Letter or
it's like if you're in a criminal trial
and you're a defendant you've got a
prior conviction that allows the jury to
think that you're not credible and
anything you say even in your own
defense is not sufficient to allow the
jury to believe you but we don't need
canceled culture because people
ostracize each other based upon you know
what they like or dislike about you but
what we've got is we've got criminal
laws we've got civil laws we've got
defamation we're the most litigious
Society in the world you know who are
these accusers who decide that we should
lose our job we should never be spoken
to and we can't allow these people who
are no names to destroy the lives of
Americans and there is no appeal there
is no regress there is nothing that you
can do to Only Time Will Heal it and it
is uh it doesn't liberate Us in fact it
it puts us in Chains it takes away our
Free Speech our ability to disagree it
is the exact opposite of what the
alleged is what do you think Jesse well
I don't believe in cancer culture but
I'll make an exception for Piers Morgan
I I want to Define what cancel culture
is I don't think cancel culture is when
some rich celebrity says something
horrible and then they lose a movie role
it's when some random person says
something and then the mob comes at him
like a hurricane and they get fired and
they go bankrupt that's cancel culture
and that is atrocious and what that
signals is that if you're an anonymous
Twitter person and you join this scary
mob and you take a scalp they consider
that an accomplishment and that makes
them feel worthwhile and all they're
doing is sitting in a dark room in their
house behind a keyboard and that means
their lives are really empty and that's
the saddest part about cancel culture it
really signifies emptiness the other
thing is is that the culture then if
it's that bad and the mob is that
aggressive and Powerful I don't think it
actually helps democracy if people are
afraid to express their opinions yeah
you might just say well I don't agree
with that I don't think there was a
problem with that you know I pride
myself my comprehension especially we
have a test today it's a c block and I
have to read the Rolling Stone article
and make sense of it and I failed uh and
this is so like I came out to two lies I
just go f i can't do it well I said why
is it good he goes well because straight
white men and other people with power
aren't used to getting pushback from the
ways they conduct themselves really and
Republicans why do they hate cancel
culture Republican leaders are bitter
over the president Donald Trump being
canceled so now they want to make it
harder for marginalized people in
communities to vote okay I don't even I
can even follow that so you're saying
you don't like the Georgia law and
that's Republicans way of getting back
for taking Donald Trump off Twitter and
white people don't want to be canceled
but now they're going to be canceled
that's why they're not yeah you took
this assignment that's the problem you
made you made a mistake you read the
package I apologize you know it was
laughable he actually called it a poison
in there yeah the poison the poison is
the canceled culture right it's what
Elon Musk called the woke virus right
which is infecting people's minds to
think that this is normal behavior right
that's the poison and they all realize
that it could come for them as well I
think the left is starting to realize
there's nothing I can do yeah yeah they
started it and it blew up in their face
yeah but we want Don Lemon to stick
around we do yeah as long as possible
for anyone to be fired ever no you're
not doing that he actually said on CNN
that I committed a racist act by
disbelieving Meghan Markle you did to
you though I did apparently so forgive
me if I don't join the campaign to keep
him in his job and you work with them
too take your office he did say like
nervous and you know what it was one of
those things we went in and within about
five seconds all my favorite pictures
have been removed well one of those ones
you were still in the building wow
that didn't bother me but the racist
thing did because it's the full thing if
you didn't believe Meghan Markle you
were racist even though she was lying
it's like we call the princess Pinocchio
for a reason I agree
The Duchess of Netflix yeah all right
between you and Megan only one is going
to go to see the king get his crown and
it's Pierce Morgan thank you thank you
all right
we got 100 years ago remember yeah you
could have started molecules and
potentially King peers
I wonder Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now